par exemple le bois ces défauts sont
plutôt sympathiques cd photos 2d moment
c'est pas vraiment de la vie privée
c'est des moments de vie beau ça me
choque pas plus que ça mais visiblement
il y en a quelques-uns que ça sauf
gilles verdez bien sûr c'est une affaire
d'argent
quand même être épargnés alors c'est le
premier ouvrage qui sort depuis la mort
de 35 euros oya à bernard motté il est
partout partout on sait pas s'il me sens
volé ou faire caca faire donc vous aimez
pas ça me gêne je trouve que le timing
haussier pas très bien choisir un petit
délai de décence aurait été préférable
donc ça ça vous cela retarde le choc moi
je gueulais une feinte alors vous ça
vous sert ou oui parce que je suis avec
tous les états et d'un volet il est
parti il est plus là et en fait ils sont
entrain isa il me sature tellement
qu'ils sont en train d'arriver à me
changer l'image que j'avais de johnny au
moment où il était vivant c'est un nikon
ça c'est une icône et on peut faut
arrêter ces services en fait y en a trop
la main pour ces français quand même oui
mais on a envie de le garder auprès mini
on a envie de le garder tel qu'il est
tel qu'on le voyait
mais là je reviens pas du nom dans le
business de la praye quoi moi je n'en
peux plus je trouve que voilà ça devient
absolument que je vous ai dit quand
l'album va sortir alors mais l'album
c'est encore une fois son oeuvre va
lasser autriche 4,3 et par dieu mais qui
est ce qu'on est peut-être c'était prévu
avant
ni dérivés alors il va y avoir les mugs
denis laissons donc c'est insupportable
et moi je n'aime pas du tout ça allait
aller sur internet et aussi la
publication le 6 juin de la dernière
interview de johnny en dvd et pour les
fans c'est un super cadeau on veut
toujours en savoir davantage là nous
présente 172 photos inédites avec des
instants de vie mais apparemment que ce
sont des archives essentiellement lié
aux années 90
donc comme cadeau c'est plutôt pas mal
alors ça fait même pas moi j'aime pas
parce que ça ça rend compte que la
famille ses poteaux là et c'est en plus
eux vu on en parle et on en parle on en
parle de l'histoire de du dis ça pour
moi c'est voilà exactement merci alors
on va comprendre un petit jet parce que
david aime bien moi j'aime bien moi le
seul truc
ben c'est sûr qu'on en fait beaucoup
avec johnny on n'arrête pas les médias
tout le monde nous les premiers bah oui
faut pas oublier que ça restera quand
même je pense le plus grand chanteur de
tous les temps français ouais c'est sûr
et ça oui mais bon qu'on fasse être
essaiera de profiter un jour ou l'autre
de sa de sa notoriété
québec on également des nouvelles de
laetitia et de laura a apparemment
apparemment ça commencerait d'abord
laetitia l'aider dans back on a vu toute
souriante c'était dans le magazine voici
à saint bar voilà ça parle ça se passe
bien elle retrouva le retrouve le
sourire franchement tant mieux pour elle
et on a également des nouvelles de de
laura qui est avec eddy mitchell quoi
dans que dans closer donc pas fait pas
ça mais c'est aussi bas on s'est demandé
si et pas plus tôt si comme ça va mieux
peut-être qu'il va y avoir un la sitcom
continue en fait le feuilleton à l'idée
continue et on le commande toutes les
semaines
le saint gilles la communication de
lecteurs elle a le droit de sourire elle
droit de revivre minable elle porte son
deuil mais c'est vrai que moi ça me fait
plaisir de voir les images où elle peut
enfin sourire voilà et le magazine voici
a sur ce mercredi ce mercredi ce
vendredi pas bon
elle va être de retour dans la capitale
française dès le début de l'été donc
c'est un peu un retour en france après
les cinq mois du décès de johnny
hallyday mais la roma supplémentaires je
les fais ton infantino c'est que
normalement l'édition devait être au à
l'anniversaire de line renaud qui va
donc avoir bientôt 90 ans ça va faire
l'objet d'un prêt sur l'a2 ou devrait
apparaître à laeticia hallyday battus
c'est une bonne nouvelle